we have breaking financial news
overnight about another bank failure
Regulators have seized First Republic
Bank and chosen J.P Morgan Chase to buy
most of its assets First Republic has
been sinking for weeks ever since
Silicon Valley Bank and Signature Bank
failed in March its stock price had
plunged from 120 a share to about three
and a half dollars CBS News business
analyst Joe Schlessinger is here to
break it all down it's the first of the
month and the first day of the week I
don't know if that's a good sign but
let's jump right into it so for people
who have an account at First Republic
what do they do now very easy nothing
your bank branches are going to open
today 84 branches from First Republic
are going to open all the deposits are
going to be safe so remember in Silicon
Valley Bank there was a real question
because there wasn't a purchaser for
Silicon Valley Bank so the government
had to come in and say wait all the
depositors are safe and we are insuring
everyone they don't have to do it this
time because JPMorgan Chase is coming in
buying all the deposits buying most of
the assets and that really does mean
that all the consumers who have Accounts
at First Republic can actually relax
because you're just going to walk into
your branch if you need some help
JPMorgan is going to make those
transactions everything's kind of cool
one other thing I should just mention is
that when we had the problems at First
Republic there were 11 big banks that
injected money 30 billion dollars total
into the bank to kind of help the
depository base rise they're also going
to be made whole from this deal so the
Federal Reserve released a report on
what happened at Silicon Valley Bank
what did we learn from that I think this
was a stunning report I know what
happened and Friday so a lot of people
focused on playoff weekend but what's
really important in this report is that
the FED is saying we messed up and they
said yes there was bad management at
Silicon Valley Bank but as the bank grew
in complexity we kind of took our eye
off the ball because we saw problems we
didn't escalate them quickly enough and
that was a problem and reality bottom
line they said when we saw a watering
down of regulations in 2018
across the banking sector that the tone
at the top of the Federal Reserve meant
that people weren't paying as much
attention this is incredibly important
it's like a Maya culpa that we don't
usually see among banking Regulators
they're the best Joe appreciate you